okay thank you very much
how well we refer to it attacks the rich
is a slogan that's occasionally heard
from politicians but it's not an idea
that normally finds much favor with big
earners former city trader gary
stevenson though is one of a group of
millionaires campaigning for just that
he's calling for a wealth tax and it's a
message he took to a food bank in
chancellor richie sunax richmond
constituency in north yorkshire last
week he is his personal view on what
ministers should be doing i come from
ilford east london um
from to be honest a pretty poor family
yeah we had a small little
terrace house next to the railway i
shared the bunk bed with my brother um
yeah we were pretty poor growing up um i
know what it's like to be poor
i was always good at maths and economics
so studied hard worked hard
kids studied hard in school i was able
to get a good job as a trader in the
city scarborough going in here yeah it's
been a few years i was city bank's most
profitable trader in the world basically
um
but i did that by basically betting that
the global economy would be very weak
because we wouldn't deal with inequality
so
yeah i mean it's kind of a crazy story i
went from being very poor to being very
rich by betting that inequality would
grow and that would keep the economy
weak reason why if the wealth is being
held by a small minority rather than the
big group that is bad for the economy
very very simply is because rich people
save the vast majority of their income
and ordinary people spend the vast
majority of their income the idea which
is most likely to do something at the
moment is the wealth tax because this is
an idea instead of taxing workers you
just attack super wealthy families at
the moment these guys often pay you know
less than 10
tax on their income and nothing on their
wealth which is you know less than i
paid you know less than most of you
probably paid
billionaires and millionaires who have
made a huge amount of money during kobe
well actually no he raises national
insurance which attacks on your wage
which does not affect the income of
billionaires so
listen richard sunak if you're watching
you know
call me up i'm sure you're a great guy
we can have a tea you know i'm up in
your constituency
but the way you're dealing with the
crisis is not right
cary stevenson's message to rishi's soon
act there jamie driscoll is this
something labour should be adopting can
you make it work or can rich people hide
their wealth well that's the whole point
of a wealth tax is it is actually very
hard to hide your wealth because when
we've got a strange situation where
people are working for a living doing
something productive end up paying very
high rates of tax by the time you are in
national insurance and yet if you are
managing to squirrel away your money
somewhere and and through various tax
avoidance schemes you're not paying tax
and you're getting huge windfalls
sometimes from just stock prices rising
and things like that so should should
the labor be prepared for adoption yeah
would you like to talk about yourself
i'd love to see one percent one percent
there's a number of mechanisms proposed
but it's as simple as
3.4 million every pound you've got above
that you pay a penny
uh it means if you've got four million
quids worth you know your house the spur
picasso and the downstairs loot then um
you're paying six thousand pound a year
i rang if you've got four million quids
worth of assets you can afford six grand
a year uh dana davison we talked about
how to raise money is this the perfect
way um i'd be dubious without seeing
more detail and i think the problem is
often when world taxes are talked about
they're talked about in quite roundabout
ways without getting into the
nitty-gritty and i know the wealth tax
commission did a report in this in
december 2020 and they said one of the
most difficult things is whether it'd be
an annual on an annual basis or a
one-off one-off much easier but still
the kind of the difficulties in actually
working out people's wealth and getting
an agreement between the tax man and the
individual can be really tough we saw it
with michael jackson's estate it took
eight years to figure out what it was
one off idea of having a wealth tax was
it was the equivalent of putting 9p on
the basic rate of income tax so the
difference that would make
it could do but as i say we need to see
more proposals but my view is we keep
taxes down keep taxes down you know
you're worried about i wish it was if
there's any donors watching send me a
bit of cash
all right okay we'll look at that
uh well gary stevenson mentioned the
decision to remove the increase in
universal credit and that's one of the
problems which charities have identified
as hitting some of the poorest in the
region we discussed it here of course